what will life be like in a early Mars
colony
let's take some stages in terms of how
we might do things on Mars there is
exploration somebody going out and
coming back the next stage should be
some sort of research station you will
mostly resupply it from Earth cycle
people in and out on a regular basis I
would contend that that would look a lot
like Antarctica
you don't have to fly into space
obviously to go to Antarctica but it's
not easy to get to and it's not easy to
sustain life there at the very bottom of
the world
there's a cheerless land where the long
night is a hundred and twenty-five
degrees below zero and murderous winds
howl all at 200 miles an hour across a
desert as desolate as the moon before we
used to send people to Antarctica they
cross don't Arctic continent and came
back and waited three four years before
you send the next expedition then in
1954 a dozen nations decided to ban 50
stations built around the continent now
the emphasis shifted to sign today you
literally have hundreds of people who
actually live the infestation throughout
a year there are more scientists working
in Antarctica today from more different
countries and there probably have ever
been in the past and what that means is
globally we need to think about how we
collaborate and manage and work together
I think it's a good model for how policy
and engineering and politics can come
together to produce great science
McMurdo Station is a kind of analog to
the kind of activity we hopefully want
to do on Mars some day because McMurdo
is in fact a city this is where you have
infrastructure where you have power
where you have supplies we have
everything from people who cook the food
to people who prepare science cargo we
all live and work together and we have
essentially one goal and that is to
support this science what happens in the
NRT is what will likely happen on Mars
will create a kind of early version of
community and what we really want to do
is make sure that we understand how
humans can cope with the next level of
risk living on Mars
trying to feed everybody and coping with
different visions of what should happen
next
and that's going to require a much
different level of understanding how to
do this we'll get there we just got a
move to it in steps